when it comes to good movies there's a
lot that rides on the actors
performances some roles can be played
without a great actor at the wheel and
when an actor is at the height of his or
her game one unforgettable performance
might be enough to nudge an okay movie
up into an award-winning film in the
case of these films these actors
performances were so strong that they're
practically perfect bringing the fury
she may not be the title character but
make no mistake the star of Mad Max fury
road is definitely Charlize Theron
Imperator furiosa she's the heart and
soul of George Miller's gorgeous
post-apocalyptic Road war movie of
course it was Miller who gave their in
such stellar material to work with but
it's not hard to imagine the character
falling flat in the hands of a less
capable actress with Theron behind the
wheel furiosa is every bit her name a
woman of determined fury hell-bent on
freeing immortan joe's brides from lives
of torment Farren creates a true modern
icon embellishing her determination with
a quiet empathy that shines through in
some of the film's calmer moments as
furiosa finally achieves her ends and
takes on the big bat she grunts what's
become to be the defining line of the
film remember me we sure do and we'll
continue to do so for years to come
making depression hilarious Ryan Gosling
seems to have dedicated much of his
career on screen to defying expectations
after blowing up thanks to a turn in one
of the most beloved romance films of all
time
Gosling took on a litany of strange
uncomfortable roles in order to distance
himself from the traditional career of a
leading man in Hollywood this has given
us films like the nice guys which may
well mark goslings finest hour as an
actor Gosling takes on the role of
Holland March a depressed alcoholic
private investigator in Los Angeles
circa 1977 March is vulnerable cowardly
and apt to self-harm there is a shocking
degree of drama sprinkled throughout the
performance considering the film as an
action comedy and Gosling sells marches
darkest moments just as expertly as his
funnier ones at the same time he's also
hysterical in the movie his may just be
one of the great comedic performances of
the decade
the kind of timing to perfectly foil
Russell Crowe's straight band routine
Munich one guy without his balls
it's a difficult contrast of balance
playing a life hating alcoholic who's
funny without compromising his
characters identifiability
it takes an actor as talented as Gosling
to pull it off burning it down even the
best films in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are often marred by bland
unmemorable villains with vaguely
defined goals and personalities there
are occasional exceptions like Loki
surprise but for the most part Marvel
villains are uninteresting that changed
though when Michael B Jordan hit screens
is Eric kil mandra Stevens the
antagonist of Black Panther Jordan melds
swagger with terror painting kill monger
as a sympathetic character who's just a
few adjustments away from being the
film's protagonist his background as a
poor kid in Oakland California feels all
too familiar so much so that the
audience is more likely to relate to him
than to two challahs royal upbringing
his ultimate inability to distinguish
justice from aimless violence is all the
more heartbreaking because of how close
he is to being someone we love
Jordan's charming recklessness and
seething hatred make for a character who
feels doomed from the moment we meet him
yet seeing him finally meet his tragic
end still hurts
Jordans had some sizable performances
before of course but this one is
absolutely unforgettable besting the
braggadocio it's always incredible when
a young actor manages to not only hold
their own in a film featuring a slew of
major movie stars but manages to come
out as the standout performer in the
film there are a few better examples of
this than Hailee Steinfeld's turn in the
Coen Brothers remake of True Grit
Steinfeld scored the role of Mattie Ross
from a pool of 15,000 actresses and she
was just 13 when she began filming on
what was her first major movie role True
Grit tells the story of a young girl who
hires a drunk US Marshal named Rooster
Cogburn to help her track down the man
who killed her father
and while Steinfeld acts alongside heavy
hitters like Jeff Bridges Josh Brolin
and Matt Damon in the movie she steals
every scene she's in her take on Ross is
snappy
angry and fierce with Steinfeld
channeling the characters laser-like
focus on vengeance with the kind of
poise most actors four times her age
aren't capable of portraying some stars
go their entire lives without turning in
a performance as authentic as the one
Steinfeld crafted and she did it on her
feature film debut it doesn't get much
more impressive than that humanizing the
eight motion capture performances are
becoming just as impressive and
important as live-action ones and
there's no one better at putting on a
hi-tech computer suit than Andy Serkis
the actor has portrayed quite a few CGI
enhanced characters of notes including
Gollum from the Lord of the Rings
trilogy supreme leader snoke from the
new Star Wars trilogy and Caesar from
the Planet of the Apes trilogy and he
really shines in that last role as the
simian soldier not only is his
performance in the role among the best
of his career but it may just be the
most important motion capture acting of
all time throughout the films we see
Caesar evolved over the course of
several years in the beginning he's a
sweet loving primate whose intelligence
is obvious but whose otherwise pretty
innocent by the time we get to the last
film however he's soulful resident and
all-too-human Circus takes the character
on a journey from a young ape confused
by his place in the world to a grizzled
unbreakable leader of a new nation and
his performance never once falters along
the way yes
the special-effects crew does a stellar
job in transferring that performance to
animation but at its core circuses
tremendous work proves that he's a true
pioneer in motion capture acting
matching the tempo JK Simmons has pretty
much always been impressive from his
gritty work on the small screen to his
memorable foray into the superhero realm
to his versatile film appearances he
doesn't seem to miss even his insurance
company commercials are worth watching
but Simmons magnum opus is his role as
Terrence Fletcher in whiplash in the
film he portrays the jazz professor from
hell a maniacally focused and demanding
conductor who berates abuses to students
until they either achieve brilliance or
go insane his simultaneous mentorship
relentless antagonism of miles tellers
Andrew is both engrossing and repulsive
Simmons strikes the perfect balance of
mania never going so over-the-top as to
ruin the audience's suspension of
disbelief and yet there's a humanity
Simmons gives to Fletcher when he easily
could have been a cartoonish monster
there are plenty of great iconic movie
antagonists but Fletcher's realism makes
for one that will haunt any young
artists deepest insecurities elevating
the material it goes without saying but
Meryl Streep is one of the greatest
actors of all time
her filmography contains a multitude of
flawless performances which makes
picking just one sublime showcase next
to impossible that said there is one
character who simply would not have
worked without her and that's Miranda
Priestly in The Devil Wears Prada the
film is based on the novel of the same
name which tells the story of a college
graduate working as the personal
assistant to a tyrannical
editor-in-chief of a fashion magazine
the film and her role as Miranda
Priestly should have been a relatively
forgettable one but with Streep coming
in and bringing her a-game to the
picture the whole movie is lifted from
simple dramedy status to an absolute
must see that will stand the test of
time Streep's infinitely quotable Ice
Queen bears an unwavering facade of
steely perfection yet she lets that mask
slip just long enough to allow our young
heroine and the audience by extension
see the humanity that lies beneath all
that brass it's one thing to act well in
an already well crafted film but it
takes a truly magnificent performer to
turn a role like Priestley into an
oscar-nominated performance if Streep's
screen talents weren't already
documented enough her work in The Devil
Wears Prada proves that there's simply
no one as good or as effective as her
being a man there's very little to say
about pulp fiction that hasn't already
been set Quentin Tarantino's master
class in filmmaking is arguably the most
quotable movie of a generation and most
of the best lines came from samuel
l.jackson jules a righteous hitman who
finds himself in the midst of an
existential crisis over the course of
the film
Jackson is extremely prolific as an
actor and has appeared in a number of
Teno films but it's his turn here that
stands out as one of his finest hours as
an actor there's a calm controlled
intensity to jewels that lingers
throughout Jackson's performance he
calculates everything and almost always
has the upper hand which is why his
near-death experience in the film shakes
him to his core Jackson makes this
experience lesson unraveling and more of
a crossroads for the character it makes
his encounter with petty criminals Ringo
and Yolanda all the more riveting a
pivotal consider the controlled rage and
desperation that goes into every line
and what's Fonzie like mondo in a film
filled with memorable characters and
performances Jackson's stands out as the
definitive performance in one of the
great modern American films channeling
the insanity films based on Stephen King
books provide countless stellar villains
to choose from from Jack Nicholson's
Jack Torrance in the shining to penny
wise from it however there's one that
seems to stand out from the rest
even all these years later Kathy Bates
oscar-winning turn as Annie wilts in
misery Wilkes is fan culture gone toxic
well more toxic than it already is her
attachment to writer Paul Sheldon's
novels as fanatical leading her to
kidnap him after a car accident
oftentimes when a villain is so
memorable it's because the actor brings
a relatability one wouldn't expect to
the Roy the wilts is just not that kind
of woman her performance is of someone
so unhinged and unpredictable that it
frightens you to your core what do you
think I say when I go to the feed store
in town oh now Wally give me a bag of
the Effie pig feed and ten pounds that
[ __ ] leaked alcorn Bates plays Wilkes
is a woman who truly believes her
behavior is normal which makes it all
the more horrifying when she lashes out
at poor Paul Sheldon sure it's the leg
smashing seam that really got everyone
talking but it's Bates full package
villainy that rattled everyone's nerves
for the long haul
this is what you're looking for thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]